you
there we go number seven lucky number
seven let's get this one kicked off will
Bob sled is that a phrase or a name is
that really your last name bobsled
or will bobsled okay who really cares
right let's try this
alright so structural defect I have to
maybe in some line simply be content
with losing my c4 pawn the c4 pawn is
weak because the square it sits on is
weak and now that's a little bit awkward
for me okay it's aimed at preventing
Bishop g5 pins alright so I'm gonna I'm
gonna go with f3 I'm gonna go with efore
I'm gonna go with Bishop to d3 I want to
have a big pond Center there might be
some sacrifices against h6 one day let's
see how black develops pieces there's a
plan of b6 knight c6 to a5 Bishop a6
pointing here and I pretty much
abandoned the idea of trying to hang on
to this pond so let me swing the bat
completely around there is there are
some maybe tricks with taking here Queen
h4 but it's never really enough it'd
only be the Queen that's coming out to
try and cause my King a headache but
Knight takes pawn takes Queen check King
e to Queen takes here King f2 and I
think everything is quite alright so
let's just follow through my Bishop
belongs on d3 so my knight could finally
develop to e2 he's probably going to
play here okay that's an early King side
Castle I like seeing that move let me
make sure I get my knight here so I
could quickly castle and well actually
for you know what maybe well yeah
probably castle but in ID
I could have is g4 and only then Knight
g3 to f5 and if he's ever taken which he
probably needs to be taken if he arrives
on f5 then that would peel open the G
file so I think maybe this was premature
to Castle kingside I'm fine with simply
closing up the center watching over c6
there won't be any knight c6 to a5 idea
so I'm no longer I have not that I had
concerned before about maybe losing my
c4 pawn but certainly now there's not
really a quick road to get at the c4
pawn there's only one piece that could
really put pressure on it
Bishop a6 but I think his main focus
should be to just watch over f5 and I
think hmm what do I think I'm thinking
rook to e8 Knight to f8 is pretty much
the only idea black has here let's let's
try to play a little bit quicker castle
that's something I was going to do
anyhow I have ideas of g3 f4 if I play
f4 pawn takes you know if I play f4
without g3 then the pawn could be taken
and this is maybe a reliable home this I
can't believe is good because he's gonna
have to go back so that this is I think
just turning out to be a complete loss
of tempo this there shouldn't be any
compensation for the pawn if Knight here
takes takes I'm also I'm not just
winning upon but I'm now striking at the
heart of this structure d6 1 that pretty
much is not going to be accessible yeah
I don't think that this is really
working so I guess maybe oh there's that
move okay I really shouldn't be so
afraid of that Queen to d2 would defend
c3 and the bishop though I mean I'm okay
if I lose this pawn but there's no
reason to lose any material so just
develop and defend right here I could
consider taking and then pushing um
although no I'm sorry if not here I'll
I'll simply back up I wonder if g5 is
black gonna try for some maybe this is
an idea to try and hold hold me down
from pushing f4 this is this is really
the only square black has to play with
the e5 square okay if I back up I'm
losing the exchange with Knight takes
here so my initial idea was to simply
back up I'm gonna do that with the idea
that I have a space and I'm going to not
be so welcome to trades so I'm looking
really for Bishop g3 and f4 with some
preparation because there's this falling
but let me as a start back up here oh
there's gonna be pressure on this square
isn't there hmm
I should have maybe considered that a
bit more I could defend it though Queen
- a - Queen - a - I should have at least
considered that maybe I played that a
little bit too quick I should be okay
thou Queen - eh - I'm gonna hang on to
him
so if g5 is not played now now there's
no pressure on this square so I think g5
but then you know what I'm still pushing
through with this pawn takes rook takes
with the temple on the Queen and then I
get to double I think this is well the
this has already been critical for these
last handful of moves but I think if
you're not stopping this move there's
gonna be some big trouble and I think
we're gonna have some big trouble
f4 when played has the e4 square which
is unprotected but a simple Bishop d3 is
going to cover everything with then rook
a to e1 I'm ready - now push yeah unless
I'm missing any tricks and I don't
believe I am another thing
for if the knight moves Bishop d3 he's
unprotected but they're they're really
not going to be accessible however hang
on for a moment
F for Knight move C 3 and E for hit but
after F for Knight move there's Queen c2
to defend e4 in c3 I'm gonna run with
that
yeah it's run with just kicking I have a
clock advantage which is not usually the
case here I'm playing okay decision time
for the night it's two options Queen c2
is pretty much my next move no matter
what I'm sure there's ways I could be
playing with gambit upon but I see no
reason to give up upon I have him boxed
out with my bishop on g3 let's just come
over so my D next is Bishop d3 rook a to
e1 and that'll pretty much be it I don't
see a way to improve Bishop d3 rook a to
e1 and I could slowly improve okay
what's this Knight up to I'm gonna scoot
over maybe just a little bit I mean I
could play Queen here attack the knight
for a second time I could think about
pushing 'if I've like the Queen is close
to trap I'm gonna go with this one
yeah just Queen to d2 and what next
Oh actually this is a threat a very
serious one pawn push deflecting the
Queen away from the night although pawn
push takes takes there's Knight f3 but
what if I just play one prep move King
h1 then this threat is back on mm let me
just calculate a little bit g5 takes
takes
night here yeah I'm just gonna do that
okay now I'm pretty sure this is working
they didn't have much time there so
Knight f3 is a fork but I could just pin
oh I'm sorry now that the king is here I
could actually take the Queen with check
so that's not working out I mean at the
end there's a fork but my queen is
entering I have this check to just no
time as well well that's kind of
interesting I'm not going to take though
I want to watch over efore and then that
way these rooks don't become activated
if I take here there's that so let's
grab a pawn get my Bishop working and
just look for mate soon pawn push next
and again g6 is undermined all right
good game let's go back that that really
turned out to be trouble just out of the
opening it's easy to go wrong I know
I've experienced it myself on the black
end just kind of a space deficit and hmm
well there was a temple gaining or not a
temple gaining a temple loss and on your
end with that Knight H form Oh so let me
just dive in and see if we could maybe
grab a thing or thing or two from this
game let's see where we at game history
right here and let's look from your
perspective okay
names o Indian with a 3 H 3 I think is
already the step in the wrong direction
there might be a reason to hold off on
castling because of this pawn avalanche
really that could be coming down against
your Kings side you could consider c5 is
one move you can consider b6 with again
these this idea of knight c6 2 here
yeah I think this is maybe already a bit
on the slow side I don't know I can't
say for sure it's seen it it's really
striking me as a bit slow I don't know
of course this pin is quite annoying
that's true not quite sure this is an
option though this is putting pressure
on c4 Knight c6 to a5 your bishop on
here I'm looking for an attack I'm okay
again with giving up my c4 pawn so I get
this Center and this seems to maybe be a
bit too tame I don't know let's see
after that we have Bishop al what can
black do to improve that this this I'm
not so sure about what about knight c6
now that's not working here's an
important tactic if knight c6 and d5 the
knight can't go here well actually yeah
cut knight c6 d5 Knight here if Queen
check there is c6 if the Queen wasn't
there to watch over the knight this idea
of knight c6 d 595 would not be good
because of this check for example if you
could envision the Queen here on e7
trying to reinforce the e5 point this
would not be a good idea but what more
can you be doing here hmm
maybe not Castle I wonder if you could
lock up this side of the board there is
sometimes the idea of if you can get
your knight in to a5 like c5 suppose I
don't do anything with the pawn see 592
knight c6 d5 Knight here and then with
b6 Bishop d7 Bishop d7 by the way
instead of fee and ket owing well you
could still try to play against c4 but
there might be a reason to keep the
bishop on this diagonal and develop it's
a quiet looking move but the one of the
main intentions is to make sure
there's not going to be a pesky night in
driving on f5 which is likely going to
be an option for the night when he's on
e - you could see 92 - g3 and he's
eyeing up this square and another thing
with this pawn on h6 this is maybe
making life more difficult for you to
try to defend the f5 square of course
you never really want to push g6 when
you're down this dark square Bishop
weakens your f6 and h6 squares but just
just some things to be considering
surely see 592 knight c6 d5 Knight a5
and you can consider developing your
queen side and castling on the Queen
side if you want to do without h6 it's
um yeah if you're going if you want to
do without h6 maybe it's best that you
move forward with connecting your
Knights so that you could eventually get
out of the pin in a more convenient way
alright but let's let's move forward
here yeah I think this is maybe a bit
too soon the kingside castle looks
logical enough just developing stage but
it's really tough that you're not gonna
have anything neither of us are gonna
have anything in the center well maybe
me maybe the white side here with that
for break but there's nothing that
you're able to really do in the center
or the Queen side or the King side
judging by the pawn structure I'm I'm
pointing these things out cuz I don't
see I'm away where you can make a pawn
break that will be helpful to your
pieces like where's there upon break
that's going to help better mobilize
your pieces or help your position I
don't really see that whereas I have
these ideas of f4 maybe g3 with f4 or g4
Knight g3 to f5 it's tough it's tough to
come up with a clear plan and the black
side unfortunately so Knight h5 was
tried and either go back and then this
is just a huge loss of time where you
try to play a gambit
that was the approach in the game but it
was never really enough and I don't know
that I really overlooked anything from
this point I was thinking here
right around here instead of the rook
move maybe your best tries to try and at
least secure your knight position on e5
maybe that's the best that you can hope
for here is this g5 move but then again
it's there there therein lies the
trade-off yes you can maintain your
knight position on e5 but at the same
time you're allowing me to open up the F
file and activate both rooks so it's
kind of tough okay so let me just move
forward I don't think there was anything
more really I just had to be a little
bit careful over my f3 square but yeah
it was never really working out okay
time as well all right um I'm not sure
really what more to add I guess to be a
little bit more careful with that castle
move again I've I've done it myself it's
easy to go wrong out of that opening on
the black end okay
good game
you